greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by and I'd like to introduce to the
church or what's happening now Robin
Hood Robin Hood is an investing act that
lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and kryptos all ready for this
commission free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just the wealthy bums like us
non-intimidating way the stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence simple intuitive
clear design and the Dana presented in
an easy to digest type of way I look I
want on the app my wife beautiful what
I'm going to do today is listen Robin
Hood is giving listeners a free stock
like Apple for the sprint to help you
build your portfolio do you I do you
have a portfolio this is what I'm
talking about we jumping up and down
down you think it's a party wait till
you're 50 and you're like I'm gonna be
16 I'm not go that's not a dime I got
nothing
you gotta get a portfolio you understand
me and it starts right now with Robin
Hood they're gonna give the church
family a free stock like Apple for the
sprint to help build your portfolio sign
up at church dot Robin Hood calm again
that's church dot Robin Hood calm let me
ask you a question your folio yourself
from five years ago and you've got Dan I
looked again what happened to that guy
trust me it happened to me yesterday
where'd all those wrinkles come from
when did I start looking like my dad
listened hymns is the answer for you you
know why most guys don't nearly enough
do enough for the skin despite all it
does for them soap and water just ain't
enough to prevent aging
that's why hymns comes into the party if
it's your skin do you do you want to be
a face in the crowd or a face in the
crowd what do you want to do you want to
look like Johnny Bananas or you want to
look like Johnny boombox
it's up to you order today right now I'm
gonna give you $20 off your first month
for hims anti-aging kit lock in those
looks right now you don't look beautiful
hmm and get your first month of
anti-aging with $20 off it
when I did the look it's a Bella Figaro
all right go to him calm slash Joey SC
that's for him FOH fo r hims dot-com
slash Joey SC for hims calm slash Joey
SC also come on dudes it's football
season you took a [ __ ] meeting this
week you took a beating because you took
Denver given points on the Lord's Day
which they would have sucked me into
that's why I turned on the game and I
saw Oakland was [ __ ] of winning and I
go aw dang let's start [ __ ] people in
the ass and then when the games came on
I saw New England was down dirty what
the [ __ ] and three which meant guess
what they're doing they're already
starting to [ __ ] you in the ass now are
you gonna get paid you gotta pay the
book this week that's what I'm talking
about this walkable Joey comes in you
know who I got that me in my corner my
bookie well I only recommend the service
to my listeners that's been good to me
that's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie you win they pay you
Jesus they got in game live betting
over-unders on fantasy points scored and
the most rewarding player perks in the
business so do me a favor go to my
bookie but you gotta go and do a deposit
after seven o'clock Eastern Time that's
four o'clock California time that means
if you wait though for clunky an
additional twenty five bazookas to play
on deposits over 100 bucks join my
bookie and will match a deposit dollar
for dollar use promo code Church to
activate the offer visit my bookie
online today
that's my bookie and don't forget to use
the promo code Church take this [ __ ]
meal bleep Wednesday more than I got the
beautiful talented and in Hollywood they
use them she's amazing if they check
ain't gonna [ __ ] you get two checked in
with parents every month but you're the
real dough missus I want to welcome to
the show miss kita Meghan just you just
do everything you just do everything and
over the last year I've really been
impressed with your facebook we met
through Becky worth while they were
doing the Jiu Jitsu podcasting I was
telling you that I met you briefly I was
in a Russian one that I was at the store
hanging out
by the wall and I see this amazing
looking woman walk in and I look close
like I [ __ ] know her and it was you
he would dialed up and hugged me and I
remember getting a weird energy from you
and telling Becky like she's the real
deal or something and then I didn't see
you much you know and we lost contact
I followed you on Facebook and you just
oh you've never complained
in fact you wrote something a few weeks
ago months that you have to put action
behind your faith and I nearly died when
I read that it's like you and the
[ __ ] super wrestling costume and it's
what I talk about people that people
want things but they don't commit to the
universal you get nothing back then
those words can't be any true put action
behind your faith you never complain
about color you never complain about
nothing it's always you knocking the
[ __ ] out of somebody getting beat up on
an HBO show 104 right the second season
yeah so you were born and raised here
born and raised San Fernando Valley how
old was the first time you walk into a
martial arts studio I was five years
five years I got four years ago in tenth
planet yeah I did not grow up a martial
artist at all what did you grow up doing
track basketball and gymnastics college
all the way through college four years
degree UCLA what did you major in
theater and was martial arts on your
radar at all there nothing what did you
do it for exercise track okay so when
you weren't [ __ ] out you were running
yeah exactly would you run all year um
I'm a sprinter I ran the 400 so I would
always be in the gym or training on the
track yet I saw pictures of you running
on your facebook with a [ __ ] bikini
on the beach last week I couldn't show
my daughter because I show everything
you do it's really weird that you just
it's not stop I tell people that in this
town you have people who are fakers
that they come to you they want to meet
for coffee and they want to blow smoke
up your ass and then there's people who
would do us and you don't hear from them
they check in with you from time to time
but they're always doing it and they
promote it in a way that's very lightly
and not like look at this [ __ ] it's in
your face you know exactly there's
nothing worse than somebody shooting a
same movie and they're taking pictures
every day of dolph lundgren
at 60 I want to see who is gonna get
released in Germany don't show nobody
showing it all right if I did a movie
released in France I would show nobody
you understand you mind your business
I'm not part of a nothing I've done a
thousand bad movies oh no no no hey like
I did it basically for sag insurance
like I just need sag but now I've been
with sag over 10 years so invested yes
so I get level 2 how long have you been
with sag four down since 97
god damn you got me by yeah oh no baby
together yeah 97 97 when did you see you
graduate UCLA when did you book your
first acting yeah I booked my first
acting gig at a high school so um my
senior year in high school I had to take
an elective because I was on a
accelerated program to get out of school
early because of what happened to me so
I had no interest in acting but I didn't
want to do woodshop I didn't want to do
cooking so I was like I guess I'll just
take drama and and I loved it it made me
it it helped me with the PTSD that I was
suffering from and at that point and I
bet I knew that's what I wanted to do
nothing else made me know what happened
my freshman year in high school I got
bullied by eight black girls and then
they ended up beating me up
broke my jaw my shoulder blade for my
ribs
they were stomping so hard on my body
that my pancreas in my liver were like
obliterated this is here the sanford
aird over yeah
North Hills Monroe High School what is
it like a game no it was that just just
a group of girls that hated on me I'm
half black and I have long hair and
white skin and they didn't like that and
what was your first real
from when you were in the hospital you
know it had gone the bullying had gone
on for so long that the day that it
happened I kind of just surrendered
because I was so [ __ ] over it I
really was I was so over hating going to
school
hating waking up just I literally hated
school all of my high school all of
those years and when it finally happened
I was just like just glad it's over like
it's added up to say but I was happy was
any vengeful thoughts in your heart I
mean no um I didn't I didn't really even
have a vengeful thing I was just sad and
mad at the world that people like that
existed no brothers listen I have an
older brother uh get involved he did it
because right before that happened my
parents got divorced so he was in
Redondo Beach and I lived in the valley
with my mom now after this Apple charge
is oppressed yeah I pseudo LAUSD okay
and the girls were not allowed to stand
by you know they I never went back to
that school I left the school district
then I went to Redondo and um I never
saw them again
other than the trial in the deposition
and it was just a bad experience all the
way around no it definitely is at that
point now still you're an actress
nothing's going on you're still not
thinking of taking a [ __ ] boat class
no Billie Blaine okay so I'm Victoria
okay so you took this tae-bo at this
point just for exercise not really
thinking the last thing on my mind was
that oh [ __ ] I need to know how to
defend myself I don't even know why that
never happened I think I was just I was
so sad I was so depressed like literally
I was suicidal like I just I hated life
I hated my life and I didn't understand
how I was dealt that card like for real
this this is my life like my mom got hit
by a car my parents get a divorce and
now I'm getting beat up for something I
can't help like thing this this world
sex I don't know
any part of it the girls that beat you
up with a white black girls black girls
and some endless tremendous like I'm
black black on black home all this [ __ ]
by people have gone through over the
years and you see black on black crime
it's just the biggest mind [ __ ] it's
like for real
yeah like when I watch all these
documentaries of the Crips like I got
locked up with a big-time [ __ ] and I
love them yeah he was my brother and I
loved them haha
it likes this was later he calls me I'm
out of the halfway house I'm about to
have a kid and he would give me piles of
money like he just loved me we became
partners in there he wasn't another
butters listen to me legit guys legit he
had seven women and he was supported and
five of the mad were babies mamas this
is 1987 he was paid he was beautiful hey
he was a beautiful young brother with
dreads like that cornrows you know hey
Cuba Cuba unless he would have liked
this is the only expression he had
[ __ ] on like that yeah like he would
have one visit really I made it my
assistant of the stockroom so just
imagining six chains six people there's
a point I for I love them so much and
the kitchen staff was all black that I
got him a job in the stockroom with me
and that's when the stockroom blew up
exactly being hit while holding steroids
in charge of the Vig you know he's one
of those black dudes that was sagging it
would never wear shirt yeah he was just
yoked naturally but not really up he was
model yo okay he was a black model he
didn't even know he was out there
slinging cocaine from LA to Denver so he
got pinched on federal code and he had
seven [ __ ] on lockdown and Lee one
wouldn't come like so on Monday and
Tuesday
me and him would have visitation I would
make
come from 11 to 1 no panties I would
address and we could eat lunch and then
there was a little window so I could
give her a stab and just look out the
window like at the guards and then Cathy
would leave at 1 and tolerate pops was
his name god bless his soul I looked him
up I don't know what happened he would
bring her one of his ladies and from 1
to 3 and then another one from 3 they're
like six and he would have sex with both
in one day you know he was a [ __ ]
virile and we were both the same age 26
27 he was short of a millionaire all of
them had [ __ ] it's a cause like we
were talking about cause exactly my one
[ __ ] drives that car she's holding it
down for me and [ __ ] like this and me
and him at night when hang out he's not
a mother's and it was just great it was
just crazy he got out of jail and he
calls me up one night he gives me like
two g's a little bag of coke he shows up
again when letting us come on take a
ride with me and he was just being him
the car goes switch with me
they don't want me to switch you you for
he wasn't gonna shoot up this place they
ain't pay me my fee and I drove just
shot the place down Jim oh by the ages
stop the building down like a 2:00 in
the morning it was close they just want
me to shoot it down and get messy you
know what my days my days are done with
this [ __ ] but I love them I love them
yet we gotta stop it doesn't matter like
I'm black right there was so much of it
in that jail and it would piss me off
like when brothers against the arguments
the ego and [ __ ] yeah and there was two
main ones it was a graveyard that was
what he called himself
does that put [ __ ] in a
graveyard and [ __ ] and then the other
guy was a Spencer Antoine and they will
a self-proclaimed leaders and then in
Clary's crypts
no Bloods and Crips in there at that
time and if there was there were a piece
I think you said the first guy was a
blue my brother was a creek
my brother at the time was a [ __ ] that's
the way it worked out but I guess in
there they had the truth and they will
call each other slobs that's what the
Bloods backwards the slobs I don't know
I don't get involved I just I just yeah
so then you started acting what did you
book your first thing you said red eyes
right out of high school and independent
film and you just kept going yeah I
loved it playing someone else was always
better and easier for me because I had
so much self-doubt and hate after what
happened and after like my life um I
just I didn't like this so playing
someone else was always easier
what made you walk into a tent planet
will use this that well um three and a
half four years ago I had an audition to
first 2014 yeah you walk into bloom at
ten finest for an audition and I booked
the audition and they comped or paid for
three months of jiu-jitsu
I had never I literally took a private
at 24 hour fitness North Hollywood in
the spinning room to understand
grappling so I learned like guard and
like don't go on your back don't turn
your back just so I can like make it
through the audition but I had no
martial art experience so I actually
booked the audition but had no clue what
I was doing um I had to get somebody off
my back so there was someone on my back
I just had to get her off so being an
athlete and I'm strong I got her off my
back not with any type of skill or
technique but I guess they just wanted
to see if you have it and so for those
three months I was so intimidated didn't
did not know who Eddie was didn't know
nothing about Sun planet didn't know
what jiu-jitsu was just sat there and
watch and was like this is weird that
you guys are just signing up to get
choked out and like maybe get something
broken like this is weird and scary and
then finally I was just like them let me
try it and I rolled one day and I was
like well this is [ __ ] crazy there's
someone trying to hurt me right now and
I'm supposed to like try to hurt you
back but once I was able to wrap my mind
around it and the beauty and the art of
it then I
full force and I just stayed i never
till this day I still have not trained
you Jitsu anywhere else you just got in
your purple belt in jujitsu and then how
did the muay thai get in and one of the
jiu-jitsu practitioners at tenth planet
said to me like you would love more thai
and I was like I like Thai food did not
even know what more time and he was like
now it's kickboxing and I was like oh
are you Thai bow and he was like no it's
not Ivo it's real you'll like it like I
watch you roll and you're so aggressive
like you should try it and I was like
okay so I went one Saturday to the yard
and loved it I was like this was the
hardest [ __ ] I had ever done in my life
I almost wanted to throw up I didn't but
it was a very hard workout and it was
unlike anything and it made me feel very
uncomfortable like putting everything
together I felt so uncoordinated and
stupid and I just thought that was
empowering to get over it I saw it as a
hurdle so I signed up for like six
months and loved it and that's how I
that that was my introduction to more
Thai and then you don't fight yet yeah I
fight oh then no now I do know now then
when does welcome it
so then around that time I had an
audition for what I thought was remember
that show heroes on MBC yeah and it was
like sci-fi yeah okay so I had an
audition for heroes I go sign in sitting
in the room and then they called my name
I go in and there's a wrestling ring in
the in there and there were girls doing
a demo and I was like the [ __ ] hold on
like pull up my phone like I swear this
said heroes but my agent sent me on the
wrong audition this was Wow superheroes
so I was like oh hell no like the girls
were big like I'm tiny and they're
throwing each other around suplexing you
know big drops slamming and I was like
yeah no I'm good so I crossed my name
out on the list and had my hand on the
door like literally about to leave and
one of the producers slash creator of
the whole of glow and Wow his name is
David McLain was like hey you're leaving
and I was like yeah I'm on the wrong
audition I thought it was for heroes but
this is progress
I don't know how to do that I don't have
any interest in that that's scary
especially with everything that happened
to me so he was like well it's five
o'clock on a Friday you might as well
just stay and I was like good point I'm
not gonna move in LA I'll still be in
the same place in one hour so I just
stayed and watched and the last girl who
did a demo was slightly taller than me
but very thin and she picked up a girl
likely size and slam the [ __ ] out of her
and I was like how about what did she do
that that was pretty awesome and I was
like this is cool like what if what if I
could do that like I don't know so I
took the waiver I didn't want to do it
but I took the waiver um I was talking
to my dad my dad was president vice
president of marketing for Blue Cross
for like 18 years so very good marketing
brain very creative so I was telling him
like I had an audition today
and it was for pro wrestling and it was
scary and he was like how did you feel
and I was like my heart was racing like
oh my god I could die in there and he
was like but what if this is something
that can catapult you into your future
like what if this is a setup think think
big think big picture think Dewayne
Johnson he's not the rock anymore we
look at him as a mega movie star and I
was like true then he started naming
other wrestlers who have like done
something with their careers and I was
like good point okay so I just sat on it
and I showed up the next day the next
the next audition training thing that
they had it was like a week introduction
and then if they chose you you had three
months of training five days a week for
eight hours a day like you couldn't work
you couldn't do anything or you had to
have a night job so I did it and out of
the 200 girls they kept 18 and I was one
of the 18 so now I'm a pro wrestler and
how long after that the job your first
pro grassley about six seven months
later where do you do these so
originally we were in Vegas and then the
last two years we've been at the Belasco
theater and then we're still at the
Belasco and then now we're just on
access TV and you play superhero it's a
rush the bully buster and now where
there's acting for the
acting's been there the whole time I've
just always been working commercials
movies spots guest starring I've done it
since 97 so if you walked into a tease
in 2014 you established bully Busters in
2012 yes how did that entail how did
that so originally bully team bully
buster was I wanted to be I knew I
wanted to do something so so even the
concept of team bully Buster came
through a part I was playing in a really
big play in LA and we were doing like
character breakdown because the
character I was playing was raped she
was a crackhead she was homeless she was
pregnant and a drug addict I knew huh
your best friend so that girl couldn't
have no light about her and the director
picked me out of all the people that
audition but he was like I like you but
you have the brightest light about you
so we got a dim that [ __ ] and I was like
okay so we got together and we're doing
an hour of character development so he
was asking real personal questions have
you ever been raped have you ever been
molested and I was like no thank God
thank God like no but uh he was like
have you ever experienced anything crazy
where you felt helpless and I was like
well I did get bullied and it resulted
horribly and pretty much [ __ ] up my
life for a long time and he was like
tell me about it so I started telling
him about it and he was like just pause
like
sidebar from the play you need to do
something with your story the fact that
you overcame that and you're still this
happy little bubble like you need to do
something and I was like what do I do
with this shitty story this is a
horrible story to me and I never spoke
about it and so then I started praying
on it like God what do I do if I'm
supposed to do something with this or if
this happened for a reason please reveal
it cuz I don't know so show me what I'm
supposed to do with it so at that time
the answer was for me to be a liaison
for kids and schools so if a kid is
getting bullied and they can't talk to
their parents for whatever reason or
feel that they can't or they can't talk
to the faculty at school because they
don't feel comfortable enough at least
they can reach out to team bully buster
and we will contact the school on the
kid's behalf and
follow up that's literally how it
started but then I was like I want more
like we got to show them what to do so
then it started with like confidence
building skills and techniques and then
once I started to learn jujitsu I was
like kids need to know this and then
once I started learning my way I was
like and they need to know this and
that's literally if like I just kept
going with it
no bullying has been very popping in the
news the last ten years I mean kids have
killed themselves because of you know
media bullying bullying people and
social media and stuff like that I think
we've all been bullied you know we all
at one point or another reacted to a
bully
you know I'm overcome with you but they
made me get a [ __ ] lunchbox you know
and I love the hotdog stand up the
corners my mother would always give me a
couple dollars so I'd rather go to the
hotdog stand how was that independent at
five that wall kindergarten was you know
I think about mercy or lit like you
picture her walking to the corner
getting out lassies age it would be with
team belly Buster his will you would say
what's a Riverside okay if I had a walk
maybe 50 yards past a bridge from the
school and you gotta remember at that
corner if I walked another three or four
blocks
I had Central Park that's where I went
to grammar school so when I first got
here I would eat the hot dog now my
mother this chain was the same chain I
had when I was five long big-ass balls
where my mother would pull around me and
go don't let nobody touch your chain my
father had died and had to become a
little weak so she was trying to build
the man he was weird to that Riverside
she had had enough once I got into the
first grade I thought there was
something about her like she was trying
to build a man she would walk me to
school and the walk to school read me
the riot act about how a man has to act
don't let a man touch your face
you know she wanted the Cuban Guidelines
a man a Cuban man doesn't never let
nobody touch him in the face and all
this [ __ ]
so I don't remember getting bullied at
school it was one day when I went to
Central Park but I got surrounded by
three or four kids they didn't call me
spec or nothin like that it wasn't
ethnic yeah it was about the lunchbox
they wanted the lunchbox and I wouldn't
give him the lunchbox and then I had to
monkey with the lunchbox at the lunch
box opened there was a thermos so after
they beat me up the kids at the thermos
and threw it at my head and I heard the
[ __ ] glass breaking there the old
days thermoses had a glass at him and I
heard that [ __ ] break and when I
got up walked my hands and knees and I
looked at my head and I saw that blood I
ran those four blocks Lea like an
Olympic sprinter and I could feel the
blood dripping off my face I was in
shock I was crying I knew my mother was
in New Jersey so this was only be a task
I would have to run home and one of her
babysitter was home I had to hold my
head I'd be bleeding and till today I'm
you know I never could figure out who
the [ __ ] was and then my mother got
home and they took me to the hospital I
got stitched up and I'm the way that my
mother asked me why you know I tried to
lie a little bit like I was why we the
[ __ ] you'd say I've been there like
the doctors were putting the sheet on
man with a hole to stitch me and she was
yelling at me and cube I get a little
toss and on the buggy you know like what
the [ __ ] were you doing the [ __ ] Park
anyway and I want to tell you see the
fish and she's like are you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like she was just like yelling at
me in the doctors room so at this point
I'm [ __ ] crying they put the local in
and that makes you know I think as a kid
then putting the needle in a head is
unthinkable I'm gonna pass out right now
is talking unthinkable so I start
Holland and she's yelling take it like a
man you know like she's Cuban guys yeah
this is 1969 you could treat your kid
having a [ __ ] you want in this country
nobody even call the cops you could kill
a kid in front of a [ __ ] if he
was your son and they would just hop gay
he's a piece of [ __ ] and we'll throw him
behind the building and let him run my
mother's yelling at me in the emergency
room like this dish on me up and she's a
dog yeah then either you don't stand
still look
Maho Santoni I can't move on like never
see look at my the next thing you just
heard boom
and I go what's that noise and they go
your mother just passed out because she
couldn't see blood either oh yeah so now
when she woke up she woke up even more
pissed off so in the cab bro I had
bandages on my head I'm never getting
the cab she was I so read me to tell me
the story and how they took your [ __ ]
lunchbox like in her mind it made no
sense it made no sense to her like she
was also human and I remember like
smacking me in the back of the cab like
which snitches like she was that trying
to develop a man yeah you know that was
early on I had a little bit of a problem
and then she put me in when the stitches
came out she took me to her son besides
dad Wow and then I really started
getting bullied
yeah because Rahsaan his dad would make
you run around the neighborhood with no
shoes on so the kids that were on the
street would see you running with a gear
on and now the next day they're like
this karate boy show us a move that was
even worse you'd see a little trench on
the corner and there you are running in
the winter you know with no shoes on and
they would see you so now you got
bullied even more but it turns somewhere
for me like I didn't it didn't wasn't
that big and I think every kid got
teased everybody got teased but it
wasn't a bullying issue it wasn't enough
for kids to take a life like that's when
I started paying attention to what was
going on and then I saw that your thing
was called bully Busters and I really
just started thinking about it what well
it's becoming this guy but I don't know
what's going on with schools I don't
know what horrible Jerry that the rules
at schools are horrible they're their
policies are just hands-off even if
someone punches you in the face if you
hit them back you're getting suspended
or expelled or whatever I don't teach
that at my school like you know what I
teach you know what I mean if someone
hits you know you defend yourself
and I'm sure you
we'll be much happier knowing that you
defended yourself instead of coming home
the way I did all broken up but I didn't
do anything back you know what I mean
like [ __ ] getting in trouble protect
yourself and so that's a yes schools are
just out of control they have no they
they don't know what to do you know I
have a friend I get asked a kiss kid
gets a jump for punching people all the
time you know we live at a time where I
think even parenting is getting judged
heavenly you know like heavily you can't
really me I'm old school I would never
lift a hand to my daughter I don't see
lifting hands or who I do did you see
him kneeling on two [ __ ] beans for
two hours in a room I'm old school and
thinking about what the [ __ ] she did I'm
thinking about giving her a notebook and
writing I will not yell at my mother
from 3 o'clock to [ __ ] nine o'clock
and you could go to Train but I'm gonna
tell Keita that if you do one [ __ ]
somersault to do a thousand sit-ups like
you never go back literally like that's
how my mother was
Mahler they would make my or you want to
yell at me okay three o'clock for a week
she would make me right yeah everyone
every I had to be dotted to be under and
this page had to be in English and this
page had to be in Spanish I should
remember the words Yo Ma no God we're
all on the island I'll be mama that
means I will never ever argue with her
like doubt her like I used to be one of
those [ __ ] that was started
arguing when questioning just a Buster
ball and she was good at it so don't
forget in here you wanna [ __ ] with me
put the fork down you really wanna [ __ ]
yeah so it was like I could never raise
mercy the same way the same way but my
mother was trying to raise a man to
raise a man when she was single and then
when she married he did a good job the
first couple years but the more he
started getting a stream my mom knows
now
that's my son I'll raise him now I want
to and then she he left and then I did
what I wanted so in the end you don't
say - you let the pressure off which now
I know what to do when went to Preston
pressure on mercy the pressure isn't
from 0 to 10 it's after 12:00 when they
got him did you see uh have you seen the
movie about to check the [ __ ]
gambling chick the white chick about
cards
she's a gambler supposed to jail in
Hollywood no not yet you know which one
we're talking about in the beginning of
father is the guy that played with
Whitney Houston and I'll never Kevin
can't cause the place a fault and he
don't [ __ ] oh not the name of this well
look up Kevin Costner maybe some things
world
Bali's world okay marlis world is a very
good movie whatever I'm gonna play it
and it's on okay like I even if I blink
[ __ ] from Netflix I put it on because it
shows too far those perspectives I think
it's very sweet okay it shows Kevin
Costner's perspective I was raising her
and how she would go daddy I want to go
home I'm tired go give me a synonym for
the word tired and he would she would go
weak what do you want to do you want to
go home Stella she was gonna know and
she would skeet cuz he became an Olympic
skier first but then who's gonna be the
new black Jane is my my brother address
dhimmis clay is the attorney and he's
got a 12 year old daughter and she's
owned like [ __ ] points like he made
her read the crucible so he asked her
why you'd be reading making your
daughter either crucible they get to an
argument and then she is he tells her is
that why you control your daughter so
much and he's like yeah and then she
goes that's good you need to because
this is what happened my house so it's a
story about a bad dad being there and
another dad I love I watched every every
play right this week an edible yeah some
guy gave me another boy
and I either like a six and older start
passed down last he had the bump at the
end but they have a great talk at the
end of this father-daughter and it's
just now how was your father in all this
with you my dad's amazing when that
happened so a similar story when I was
getting examined in the hospital um my
mom passed out from seeing me and all
the pain when they were pushing like
does this hurt does this hurt moving my
arms she literally passed out so rewind
to before my parents got divorced my mom
was in a major car accident she got hit
by a car on her birthday um right after
my parents decided to get a divorce so
like six months her friends take her to
Palm Springs let's party girl and like
get away from the kids and the divorce
situation let's just go have fun for
your birthday they have dinner and
drinks and then they leave and a guy
hits my mom and another person that work
was crossing the street when he realized
he hit somebody he didn't see them so
then he reversed but my mom flew over
the car so he hit my mom again so my mom
was in a coma for 39 days 280 stitches
in her head pelvis crushed lung crushed
knees crushed ankles crushed risk like
everything was broken so a year to later
now I'm in high school and then this
happened so my mom was still on crutches
like her knees had to be reconstructed
like she was on crutches and in a
hospital bed for a good five to seven
years after that happened so then my mom
passes out so my dad gets to the
hospital and he's like where's my
daughter they and he's like where's her
mom and then I think she's we just
admitted her in the room next door so my
dad's going back and forth [ __ ]
daughter got beat up my my ex-wife was
passed out and like holding on a life so
it was just a lot but my dad is a marine
and he is resilient and he he was he was
just there he was an awesome guy he's an
awesome that you're still tight with oh
yeah very much yeah what's he think
about what you're doing then he's so
proud of me
I just went he just retired and moved to
Vegas last year so this past weekend
drove up there just to go hang out and
he he just always says I'm so proud of
you and I
awesome because my brother is a brown
belt in Kung Fu
and I'm like why did you not put me in
martial arts like why was I in track in
gymnastics when Javon got to do like
that and he knows how to fight and he
has protected himself his whole life and
he's like I didn't think he would have
needed it like how sad right and I'm the
one kid that gets [ __ ] beat up is me
so he apologizes the other day for not
putting me in kung-fu - you know you
never know what you need - yeah so it's
way too late to [ __ ] win yeah but
it's just I cannot believe I am blown
away that you've been involved with
martial arts only four years yeah you're
so and I took it and ran with it every
single day I train so now with this
wrestling season what does it consist of
so we just got picked up by access TV
Mark Burnett MGM studios so 2019 will be
airing so October 10th and 11th here in
LA we're shooting for next season
so right now I'm in training five days a
week every night at 8 p.m. in Long Beach
for wrestling yeah so one more training
on that but jujitsu and more thing so is
this like WWE the smaller scale yeah
it's like a UFC and then there's
Bellator can you talk [ __ ] yeah can you
curse no not necessary I come on go come
on over yeah I'm a bully buster I'm like
bring it on
I have a cool character cuz you're
either a good guy or a bad guy but I'm a
good guy that's really tough so I don't
have to just be like hey you know what I
mean I'm like bring it so I like that
they gave us a lot of creative freedom
so my character really is the bully
buster now do you have time till I shoot
a movie teach kids I don't know I make
it happen
be in Long Beach my [ __ ] eight
o'clock now leave the studio at 7-7 just
honest that I'll eat on the way there
yeah I know you can't even eat cuz
taking bumps and getting slammed off
throw up letting you stay down there
till midnight come home come home one
o'clock eat dinner you might have an
audition the next the next day how are
you how is your audition game
least of all yeah all the time I just
booked a major national for Nike shot by
Alejandro eating me - who directed the
revenant and won the Oscar for that so
that was like a godsend and I play a
wrestler so that's cool
do you still go to acting class I don't
not anymore what you want to feel that
you're back from that yeah no it's not
necessary
- like for me when I came out ago how
sure I wasn't in the beginning yet did
you do plays at UCLA I didn't at UCLA
but I did during the time so like at the
Redondo Beach Performing Arts Center
plays around here plays in LA but not
for the school okay so now you're a
wrestler you're an actress writer
now what without what day do they come
to you and say hey kita since you do
everything but fix the [ __ ] kitchen
do you want to fight - when did this
start what year did this start last year
so wait it's 2018 so 2017 my coach so I
started training at Anu I stopped doing
more Thai after I left the yard for like
a year I be honest who school Jo Jo
shelling yeah okay um so no Jo train
there for six months and then just it
just got busy and Highland Park is not
down the street and it just was
inconvenient and at that time they had
different coaches there wasn't just Joe
and Mark so I cut back on that
and then about a year ago got back into
it and started training and about two
months later my coach was like hey have
you ever thought about fighting and I
was like no I mean I I doubt I would
ever be good enough and I'm not a spring
chicken
so I he was like no you're good enough
you're you definitely got it and I
remember mark saying that at the yard -
like you're you're a fighter and I was
like really just hearing those words and
knowing my story is like it doesn't it
didn't I didn't accept it yet that I am
a fighter
um and so he challenged me he's like ah
what if I get you a fight and I was like
if you think I'm good enough I'll trust
you because I trust you and he was like
you got it and so I took a fight
I was literally learning Muay Thai at
the same time as being in fight camp
took the fight and beat the breaks off
over one you know
decision how many fights have yet
now I've fought twice morte um probably
it's up to do another one soon just
after a while I always have to like pace
out either jiu-jitsu Muay Thai or
wrestling I can't do all three
competitions you know what I mean
getting ready for all three it's a lot
no modeling do modeling - yeah I thought
no I'm too short for like real modeling
but I do
Nike hardtail like all athletic lines
Gatorade tremendous yes [ __ ]
tremendous you know you you read and
read people's Twitter's and everybody
has negativity when it comes to acting
this is what it's like being a black
woman in Hollywood this is what it's
like being though you know every time
you talk to white actors now they'll
take you aside and go I'll ask miles an
audition well you need to be black now
or an Indian or a mix to work anymore
and somebody people just give [ __ ]
somebody stupid yeah and I just I have
seen you just I follow you on facebook
I mean it it's mind-boggling I didn't
even know about the wrestling - last
night at from eight through eleven I
thought you just taught at the school
and that was it for the night you know
caught up with the [ __ ] Irish now now
I eat a bar or a shake or a strawberry
or a bite of an ass there at ten o'clock
or so at gym bully buster yeah yeah
you teach there anymore yeah every
morning go to Kravitz and then cost and
then if you have an audition what do you
do go to my audition they're usually
like 10 11 12 like so you know at Laurel
Canyon and Chandler there's an audition
place so if you're ever in a bind and
they call you it's right there and they
say to you you just come in the tape for
a [ __ ] guy with a camera but we need
to thank you for now we're just gonna
listen I'm too busy for the output on
tape and it's across the street from the
Cuban restaurant on Chandler and Laurel
Canyon once you roll over can't a Laurel
can't once you roll over Chandler the
railroad tracks right there look to your
left you pull a left in there that guy's
been there forever young' likes getting
brother okay give her 15 bucks for 15
minutes
you put your tape very [ __ ]
tremendous I book jobs okay yes if
you're gonna pay me call you you like
really Santa Monica to go out and get
the ocean right now some Chinese guy the
[ __ ] camera doesn't that toes you
know yes
I'm not saying look at my Chinese I'm
just saying that that's what is yeah and
this is guy with a camera where's the
[ __ ] producers so I came all the way
then I'm here to put to be put on tape
anyway I could put myself on tape a
little can you know whenever the phone
is now the school how long has the
school been open hold on one second yeah
let me take a break real quick we'll be
right back
let me ask you something you ever look
at the phone of yourself from five years
ago and thought damn I looked young what
happened to that guy well he's all these
wrinkles around my eyes come from when
did I start looking like my dad some
things get better with age wine for
example a nice single malt scotch
unfortunately this is not the case when
it comes to your skin especially your
face look at my face I need help
most guys don't deal nearly do enough
for their skin despite all it does for
them and if you think soap and water is
enough to prevent aging you got another
thing coming but there is something you
can do in the fight against aging and
it's staring you right in the face you
ready for hims calm a one-stop shop for
skin care hair loss sexual wellness and
men now for me listen I put a little
cream on I'm gonna try this does hims
anti-aging kits a custom prescription
cream tailored to your skin that can
just keep your skin looking youthful
smooth by reducing the appearance of
wrinkles and fine lines that's not a
secret it's treated and it's a results
of backed by science pronounced tree
e-noying tretinoin can renew and restore
by increasing collagen the protein that
keeps your skin firm it takes seconds to
apply there's the same treatment so ever
you used to keep their faces looking
young except you don't have to visit
some fancy dermatologist or pay high
prices to get it hims connects you with
the doctors online will evaluate your
skin needs and can prescribe you a
custom anti-aging treatment it's that
easy all you need to do is take a couple
pictures and answer
for a couple questions no more awkward
in persons doctor visits people looking
at you these products are shipped
directly to your door nobody knows
nothing
it's your skin do you want to be an a
face in the crowd or the face in the
crowd
that's up to you baby order now and save
$20 off your first month of hims
anti-aging kit lock in those looks now
and get your first month of anti-aging
for $20 off that's what Joey is doing to
you fit defeated a $20 loss so go to
hims calm slash Joey SC that's for hims
calm slash Joey SC for hims calm / Joey
MC get your skin looking tip-top Magoo
all right so we're talking about the
school I had a father I went outside I
don't want to fun fun icky lab they had
a protein shake and I had fish at Lisa's
he doesn't like when I eat fish I
appreciate me does that blow farts oh
you know I'm just trying to be decent
Tim thank you this is such a nice
individual how did the school come about
when the [ __ ] in this schedule did you
say to yourself you know what you know
what I think I really need to do open up
a martial art school really put myself
into a [ __ ] mind there so the way
that started as I was already teaching
self-defense at tenth planet and at team
victory Muay Thai and um where's team
victory Inglewood right right by the
airport you were teaching self-defense
for women for free for since 2012 for
free just come in just get sick on bar
yet more show wrist breaks you know rape
prevention if someone Fair hugs you how
to get out of it like more so grabs and
attacks versus just jujitsu I mean you
were doing this for free
mm-hmm coming in some of them have been
put in bad positions before abusive
relationships
date rape actual rape preventive don't
want to ever get raped or get in that
situation
I got a present for and I'm gonna hit
him so hard as father's gonna fall out
of the sky these flies William Thomas so
they follow him no you keep well you
keep rolling afterwards they you can
[ __ ] door right now can that fly
believe this [ __ ] has had a fly
on top of him for the last two years
since Ralphie May was alive one day
brought a bee in here
when they brought like a flying squirrel
pin from Miami because they follow him
cause he eats that humus and they're
attracted to the humus in the desert so
this flies I don't know if it's hummus a
dog [ __ ] that's why I don't need hummus
because it comes out of your [ __ ]
neck
and every time Lee shows up there's a
fly copy I'm lying fully who's keeping
flies as pets no how do they tell you
Joe THC and I experiment with them oh
yeah they get [ __ ] up they take it why
I think you forgot how to fly they just
sit in the bathroom window after about
two days they disappear they know how to
fly and they're like I'm never going
back in there again that's like a chick
from Charlotte's in the land once they
get out they get the [ __ ] out of that
bathroom cuz I got a back bathroom so in
the morning as I close the door what's
mercy goes to school and I can open up
and dad's smoke sometimes I just take my
pants down take a [ __ ] with the door
open and I smoke and it it helps because
when you call for you push and
everything comes out a lot of people
don't know that technique that's called
the open window when you have don't have
more technique you just take a hit when
you go it just flies out of your muffler
people know this drop now for the time
okay so never constipated I will take
you up on so dr. Joley
what possesses you to open up a Marshall
school martial arts school which isn't
really a martial arts school you have
something very special over there
so um two years ago speaking of Billy
Blanks Michael blanks his brother who
ended up teaching and had a gym on
Lankershim and Chandler called sweat
theory sees all my posts just the same
way you do and he
hit me up randomly and he goes hey I'm
in the process of opening up a gym and
it has other rooms in it so I'm gonna
have like a kickboxing room but I wanted
to know if you would be interested in
having a self-defense room because I
know all of my clients would really know
would really want to know how to protect
themselves and I would love to have you
there and I was like what really awesome
he's like yeah just bring team bully
buster into my gym and it was gonna be
in Woodland Hills right off of Canova so
do that whole thing he had partners and
investors and then he was my partner so
started you know painting got the
plumbing the electricity get decking it
out and then something fell through with
his investors and since I wasn't the
person on it that dream just went right
but ever since that was there
anytime I'm driving and I look at spaces
I'm like ah I wonder if if I put team
bully buster there what would it look
like it's just visual I'm a visual
person I see [ __ ] and I won't stop
seeing it until it happens and one day I
was driving down Whitsett and that used
to be an art school and it was empty
and I was like oh the art school was
gone and I was like what if team bully
Buster was there I wonder how much it is
what should I do
look look so all these thoughts and so I
pulled I'd made a u-turn went next door
and was like hey do you have any
information on how to get in touch with
whoever owns this to lease it out and so
I called and they were like yeah what's
your company know you fire out yeah he's
why I know he knows uncle Joey [ __ ]
around I had this deal and then
lightning quick I'm sorry yeah maybe I
control the flies cuz he hasn't been
around me today maybe I'm just like I
used to have afraid you did a couple
lines of coke let me talk to y'all so he
goes Shh he was bought likely early bald
and he would she would say shut up for
one second he look at his forehead
laughing okay it was just so high don't
he was just so high they loved this
wouldn't imagine his bald spot he would
swallow them something continue with the
conversation again that's a good
character oh please that's good swats
really
jealous
Joey swats so so yeah so I called got
the information I filled out the
application and I was like oh no here
goes you know like I hadn't even really
been thinking about like I want a gym
like that wasn't ever there but it was
but it wasn't you know what I mean
and so they accepted it and I yeah your
application we accept it so you a first
month last month and you're signing a
lease and I was like mmm oh [ __ ] it's go
time so I literally just had to push go
and start a teen bully buster right
there
and it's you know you call a team bully
buster I'm not saying this is a negative
way or positive way is it is a positive
way when I saw your ads and what I saw
like I already was thinking about son
for mercy
well she's got a very sweet heart like a
mother she doesn't have the swine the
part that I have she wouldn't think like
that but then when you have children you
look at your children and you remember
you at that age and that that age my
father had died and that's why I got hit
in the head with the [ __ ] tool and I
was a little on the weak side that my
mother put me in karate and karate
my mom I would tell my mama I got kicked
in the stomach one day and they took the
air out of me and I'm in behind me all
I'm quitting and mr. Harmon said you
ain't quittin I don't have quitters in
this school you know this is a black
school quitters here you get the [ __ ]
up in those days that's how karate
teaches talked it wasn't right you know
and you know it wasn't mr. orange the
teacher I had after mr. Horan's that
[ __ ] you hadn't bringin me a
report card gee that's out of your club
didn't have it you came to class it did
the warm-up but you got to sit down and
do your homework and you couldn't do
drills and that was brutal language wall
in oh yeah straight A's you gotta have
straight A's to [ __ ] up mr. mr. Norland
[ __ ] or you can come here I don't want
no dummies here and he was saying just
like that and if you got a B or a see
you come to class every
des I want to see you here you're gonna
do the jumping jack you'll do the hip
escapes you're gonna do all that but
when I teach the technique in the form
in the kata you gotta sit it aside with
three other [ __ ] morons that that
changed a lot of things for people
that's a different that's a different
discipline and so I'm already thinking
about my daughter I'm thinking that I'm
55 you know things happen and you have
to accept those things and I was left
out the cold and I want her to be a
woman and to have all those things but I
also wanted her to know what the street
is like like I got a friend that I grew
up with the machinist there the - why
this chick she ever seen but Tonya don't
[ __ ] around and time you told me we both
her daughters of five she took him to
Times Square
let him go and ahead just to see their
reaction she goes bowling got an
education and then I asked him why they
didn't go to cop and their original
thing was didn't look trustworthy
you know kids see all that paint they
don't focus on the other stuff they
don't focus on rent and bills so I want
my daughter the same have that same
street furniture I want when I'm with
mercy and they see a walk-in shower oh
yeah pay attention both laugh Eva I
talked her in Spanish so it's double
like my mom used to talk to me in
Spanish
there was a point where I would go to
the park of my mom and my mom would give
me hand signals like oh yeah he's
touching you too much dog hello don't
call it means touch what's keeping by
the distance you know I want my daughter
to learn how to react to getting hit
instead of me when I got hit that day I
went down I wanted to shop I'm here I
want her to learn to get hit breathe
yeah instinctually and essentially and
know what to do and because I didn't
have that that's why I started this I
know I'm making my own lane there's not
a school like this all these things
prepare you for life life is a [ __ ]
tough situation especially when you want
to do what you really love because yeah
you've got a job working on a house and
live yo I have one day when you're 460
finally give you a
watch what you didn't really do what you
really wanted to do so when you do what
you really want to do you have to teach
it like whatever I am blown away first
of all that you have not been involved
in martial arts since you were four
because she was so good with those kids
so when she turns you know I want my
daughter had pre-k was learning karate
the guy was a mutlar range I mean I
don't know how this guy he was a there's
a mutt
his picture comes up the guys are
[ __ ] mutt it was horrible you know I
even tried that I was gonna have him on
the podcast once I kept watching him and
he kept getting Muttley ER and mom here
I cannot take the showers I go to school
with his hair sticking up but he can't
be a mother when I saw him he teaches at
a park he's got these idiots doing sword
things his [ __ ] I'm like who fight for
the [ __ ] sword and how he wouldn't
hit you don't say why you know buddy
he's just a muddy guy yeah you know and
I tried to talk to him one day and he
was like oh yeah I kind of live in my
car like he's just but he put these
schools together these little pre-k
schools that you should be doing and
you're going down on Wednesday tried to
tell a student and you teach them real
martial arts they were jumping around
they were they were just [ __ ] they
would break boards you would come in
with like boards and they all have
boards and whatever and mercy enjoyed it
but I didn't know she knew what the [ __ ]
it was for yeah and I can't talk to her
that way so I sat it down when they
during a Bruce Lee movie well and she
was [ __ ] watching that Chinese
connection scene and she was watching
because she's like this is okay but then
she went away and then sometimes do your
season and she'll sit with me what she
does and like when the women fight so
I'm like oh my god no I can't really
and then we watch the warrior woman
named the one girl kick the other one in
the [ __ ] and and then she kicked the
[ __ ] again without mercies looking
really cool little mercy shy so confuse
that thing I don't where she coming it
looked at doing karate like you do and
listen to one girl hauls off and kicks
her the [ __ ] immersively
is that allowed listen I'm gonna switch
the channel just went backfiring on that
it's funny so I didn't know what to do
but my daughter gets home from school
and right away she puts on the superhero
outfit at this Oh God someday soon if
she gets in she gives me a kiss she
disappears for 10 minutes then she runs
is in his [ __ ] whoever back girl
whoever all those [ __ ] suits and
she'll come in and [ __ ] with me and
whatever and one day I showed her a
picture you and she was young enough but
she didn't really is about a year ago I
showed you what you were doing at the
gym and she was kind of huh but she
didn't take to it and then after pre-k I
took a little Vinny but then once she
started getting on this schedule changed
so she could go to Vinnie's anyway and
you have the program and this is plain
and simple
when I was a kid I had psychological
problems
yeah age of five I had just got hit in
the head yeah and in more ways than one
first of all my mother took me to see a
black woman and she became my Santeria
godmother is she's still my Santeria
godmother she took me to see a black
woman so I I took my daughter to see a
black woman and then my first karate
teacher was also blacker than the night
like Louie Louie with the afro she was
black is the night Louie was whiter than
white you know it's a beautiful [ __ ]
Jan but it was so weird then I told you
the story when we walked out the first
day my daughter just said well that's it
I'm not gonna see many animals masters
of any I mean my wife just broke out
like she was done you know she got all
in but it's so weird how you know my
wife's a Hitler like my wife don't play
told us she goes you gonna [ __ ] around
no it was [ __ ] yeah man why don't
play the game I love it
but mercy now I've seen the change in my
daughter I've seen how much you know she
wants to go see you and I jog I'm
[ __ ] serious I
was a I've been involved with martial
arts for twenty years the worst things
that happen in my life were when I got
out of martial arts I had no control I
got the drugs the [ __ ] and I really
thought you've been involved with
martial arts for twenty years so I
[ __ ] applaud the [ __ ] outta you
[ __ ] had the wool over my eyes you
were phenomenal and as a teacher you're
phenomenal I see you know my uh the
baby's Godfather has a nine year old
kicks like a [ __ ] needle because
she's a soccer player but her hands are
one James sent me you know he sent me
the picture he goes this is the picture
of Ava I sent him the picture of her
with the headgear on he went not die die
what if she gets brain damage you know
she's [ __ ] fine just to let her know
what it feels like she liked it yeah I
thought that day was gonna be ugly I
thought that day I was like okay I
thought that was the day of truth of
mercy I know when I saw the headgear
come on I go oh [ __ ]
this might be a long conversation that
this might switch to ballet no she loved
that she loved it and I'm watching her
like I did once I got into martial arts
I became a different kid I see her to
taking it more seriously every single
every single class it's more serious and
more seriously focus before she goes to
school I'm gonna be a kiss I call it
over we do a one two leg kick then I go
to something happen say no matter what
happens remember you can always go back
to that and just focus and start over
again she looks I'm gonna I don't know
what you're going down [ __ ] you
know why because I said so
you takes that's why don't know who the
[ __ ] and you tell your cousins and your
friends you brought that in you bring
him in here with the hummus on your neck
and now he could die on your [ __ ]
neck I'm less than a thousand flights to
your house [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop eating hummus and yesterday
anonymous I thought I knew he was
show up today with a fly cuz he always
shows up on the fly when he'd sell
hummus they get him right in the parking
lot they think he's got [ __ ] coming out
of his pores they that hummus now could
you shower after the conditioning okay
good job cuz then you get the other
[ __ ] thing coming out of you you get
the batteries coming out of the
conditioned classes not shower you would
see me I'd be [ __ ] no I know but I
don't know it with you yeah because you
bring those flies in can teach you moves
he'll dissect the fly that following you
down the [ __ ] there's not a fly that's
the only move you always bring a fly at
some bug or something that's flying with
you and this because of your neck I told
you once I told you you got full or they
come in when I take a [ __ ] yeah they're
attracted to they're attracted to that
smell hummus and [ __ ] you just eaten
some Arabians hummus and then some
Arabian [ __ ] and that's a given a dollar
Isis how many times I told you to stop
try about this cute I gotta kill flies I
got to become an exterminator during my
budget every [ __ ] week a little less
graceful but know what I saw when you
brought the kettlebells on I took a
picture and send it to him he nearly
died you brought know you was one okay
then she went to a conditioning class
okay she was doing lunges with five
pound kettlebells I'm like oh my god
like this is way beyond then coach took
the stick out and started throwing the
stick out of and they're [ __ ] listen
you're making kill this over there and
the number-one thing about women is
number one is being loved by dad and
being hugged by that and the number two
thing is a woman that's confident that
knows if something goes down and I grew
up with both those type of women that if
something goes down they're prepared and
you have to see the difference
like I grew up with this chick that one
time we were to beef and she pulled out
a gun quicker than amendment
oh my mom you met oh yeah my mom'll [ __ ]
you up in a minute
so of my dad I just I don't know my it
came so late in life that thing that
thing for me I didn't have it all the
way up until you know five six years ago
but now that things there like I don't
wanna push it on where's II don't I
don't wanna I don't want to push
anything on I'm not pistol Pete's dad
I'm not gonna you know whatever she goes
for but I'll tell you one thing yeah I
got a bag in the yard the same one that
they climb mom they try to chip over yes
the heavy bottom and this time she
second I go outside and we go outside
and she does so it's [ __ ] a soccer
ball as she hits her little tennis ball
and everything at the end by herself
she'll go shooting about what to bring
what to me and then I put my hands up
and like I said I don't want her to beat
up anybody I just want her to know what
to like I can't wait for the future to
see you gonna see who to rape this dog
because they're all gonna be walk around
with they're gonna get caught and
armbars and 20 years that's how you
never see a rapist
they're gonna walk around with [ __ ] up
albums and then when they get out of
jail they sign it up in class
cuz it's the truth it's the truth
little girls are getting into you have
two or three little girls I'm gonna you
got John Jones's daughter that doesn't
know she's John Jones no I literally
literally bees she's nice and she's
taller she's as tall as me like damn
near when you get through to her
it's gonna be an amazing game yeah when
you get through to a girl and they start
member there's a thousand around the
Rousey's and they're gonna come up in
the next ten years thousands thousands
do you know what that's gonna how that's
gonna affect the way the game is now
it's 5% of women know martial art or a
self-defense thing but they wouldn't
know
what to do that's why whenever I go to
movie time I'm paddle up on a girl I
[ __ ] with them and I tell them listen
don't [ __ ] with me okay so I'm the guy
that I'm the type of gotta have this
size that's gonna come after you and try
to rape you right it's not ly right
don't [ __ ] with me pay attention to my
[ __ ] and I'm gonna [ __ ] come at you
when I spar with women yeah I go on a
call and I make everybody let hit me
like I'll put them and just let them
know stop and you'll listen I'll grab
you by the throat and I'll snap your
[ __ ] neck you better throw what you
got yeah and next thing you know there's
a skinny blonde girl she [ __ ] that's
it I got a so wired up one today I get
you know keep kicking me
keep kicking me keep kicking me because
I want you to know what it's gonna be
like that's it
tell the kids it's not they're not gonna
be nice oh my god you guys drop it on me
do this not a game
because I I went through it you know
what I mean it's not like I just grew up
doing karate and I wanted to open up a
martial arts school no unfortunately I
had a [ __ ] up experience and that's
why I'm so passionate about it I don't
want to see no little kids in a
situation that they don't know how to
handle and unfortunately we're not ever
taught especially women what to do when
someone's mean to you that's not a
lesson that we're ever taught not by
parents not by school no one teaches us
that so when we're faced with it we
[ __ ] freeze and I want no one to
freeze that steps foot and team bully
buster I want to create new instincts
and let them know you know exactly what
to do you hold your own you know what to
do it's crazy because I had that little
mental block after my dad died and I
didn't react uh you know I don't like I
said I remember getting bullied except
to get hit in the head with a lunchbox
but then when I started karate there was
one kid that [ __ ] with me and his
neighbor's really the Haitian he was
Haitian I mean it would fight to the
death
wait once a week and what you know at
first he was beating me but then they
learned how to utilize my kicks and I
would keep him at a distance and a half
like a good right hand when I was seven
a sudden this went down and one day his
dad seeing us fighting on her a dime
this time bloodied up his face
father held me while his kid punched me
and then his father walked me up the
steps and knocked on my mother's door
and my mother was [ __ ] passed out
taking a nap she was all from the night
before and I'm a Louisville at the front
door he's like the next time your Sun
hits my son I'm gonna hit him then I'm
late you my mom was all my one second
and she had the biggest knife she had in
the [ __ ] in the kitchen and she chased
him up the steps absolutely then the
neighbor that the cops came but the
neighbor came out and said that my
mother didn't have a knife but that was
just a lie so what the Haitians never
messed with us again ruination
but that woke up a giant in me like I
was never a tough guy but I was never
much to take [ __ ] after that and one of
the biggest things that got me through
my life was sticking up for somebody one
time that you know three people that I
jump up and I go no if you want to jump
him you could jump him but you got to
find him one at a time and the father
asked me who I was I thought [ __ ] you
this is the way it's gonna go and that
saved my life that put me in a different
thinking I was never a tough guy at all
if I think I beat up at a park one time
really bad I tried to mug a guy that was
like I was like Todd I come dad we're
gonna be a fighter that's never ever
gonna happen but with mercy I'm very
concerned because she's got the heart
than a mother has now like I've been
trying to talk Terry into go into your
class and she doesn't know nothing like
one time we were living in Hollywood and
she goes put your dukes up and she put
her hands up and all I did was push this
in her so she didn't really know and
this conversations been going on for a
little while of us so we're all very
happy with you and how you treat my
daughter but here it is let me drop this
on ya so cuz I just talked to my uncle
again Sunday night we have a long
conversation what pissed me off when I
came here and a knee I came here in 84
after my mother died the Sonny
to live with my uncle in Glendale and he
was very at a different point of his
life and he was kind of this chanta with
my mother and he told me things I didn't
need to know and he let me know who I
was he's like you could keep faking the
funk but you're really the son of a
killer I was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about because after my mother
died I found out that she had an alias
that's why I couldn't collect Social
Security it was because one night at a
party in late 1954 my mother and her
sister Rosita went to a party and my
mother was older by one year she lost
Rosina and she went outside and Rosita
was around getting raped by a man so my
mother took a bottle broke it could stab
the guy in the back with the bottle and
killed him they had a flutter off the
island and my mother had a very unusual
temper and she was the original like you
see all these women that March for
women's rights
that wasn't my mother's world my mother
struck with the [ __ ] with the hammer
or a God my stepfather was a good dude
he tried to really be a good dude
and one day he made a mistake of
flicking a cigarette at my mother my
mother waited three fell asleep took a
statue of a saint and busted it over his
[ __ ] head and told him that she was
back in it like [ __ ]
Shawn and not even know let's take a
right right it was oh I was just a plain
cigarette my mother wanted him to hand
it to her that's a gentleman do but he
threw that Javier mom so this is in her
these jeans over there yeah these jeans
are in her and I don't want her to be a
killer but I want her to understand that
her there in there the same way there
were me as I was growing up and I would
get those dark evil thoughts but I was
on drugs I want to be yeah but I just
wanted her to uh I thought it was very
important for her to being sometime I
don't want him to be a fighter I don't
want to I don't expect you to do
anything that's like would be happy just
know how to protect yourself how to
protect yourself is the most important
thing for a woman especially today's
world
for me I think self-defense is equally
as important as paying your car
insurance if you pay for car insurance
you pay for life insurance or you have
you know medical insurance you're
investing into your life right and it's
something that you value same thing with
our homes we put surf curity alarms and
cameras and you know same with our cars
we push the button to lock it and it's
the same thing we should do that with
ourselves giving ourselves a skill to be
able to protect ourselves so for when i
when i meet women who are like i would
love to do that but i am too scared or
out but but you get your nails done or
or i can't afford it you get your nails
done you get your highlights done you
pay for this you get this all this but
when it comes to protecting yourself
what are you gonna do and and that the
answer is always I don't know and it
should be equally as important as having
an alarm on your car having an alarm on
your house have the same thing for
yourself have self-defense knowledge you
know when you were teaching her twist
the side control
oh my god and how the choke from there
is something one that yeah they look
like a week later you put a video up
there my sweeping from the mountain and
I was like just that so important for a
woman that is so important for a woman
to get thrown down acknowledge what
position Jesus and know that she can get
up her cool
grab his sleeves put her feet on his
hips and know that she's got this guy
his momentum and his weight if she could
keep her cool and that's what it is that
I want my daughter to have her cool my
wife don't have a cold
my thanks to [ __ ] out I want my mother
she had her cool and that cool yeah you
have to learn how to react and well
that's what's made me stay with jujitsu
I walked him to Jitsu 336 pounds and I
did my first hip escape and I thought it
was the end of the world
I thought it was the ending of my world
how old were you and you started 50
fifty-five years old the first following
of you and Eddie been friends since 2099
in all those years you never were like
I'm gonna take a class from my friend I
told it was the most disgusting thing I
don't ever want touch a man's foot I
don't know what your fate when I see you
preparing for an armbar from the
mountain if I smell your ass all we're
gonna have a problem not to worry okay
all those things fungus he feet all that
[ __ ] I did not want to be involved
I joined Muay Thai of America okay and
then I realized that it was truly people
watching UFC I would get people in there
I thought they were fighters don't fire
guys stick to me the strength of ten
[ __ ] yeah this is just light sparring
yeah what's going on I need it right now
and one day I saw this jujitsu school
and I was just second I saw Joe Lauzon
yeah our UFC fighter he had a strategy
and all his fights he'd take a punch
fake it but on the way down
grab him don't take it down get you in
close guard and after that it was night
night and I read when you went to pick
up the other hand and you based you were
done Don and I thought that was the most
brilliant thing I had ever seen right
there I knew what jujitsu was I knew was
invented for a little guy against a big
guy this is so what's a little guy
against a big guy equate to a woman
I got 280 pound man which is the average
weight of a man that's what you Jitsu
was really benefits from jiu-jitsu if a
woman can breathe and keep her cool
while the guys trying to take his belt
buckle off and take his dick out and
while he turns she breaks his [ __ ]
hell ball or chokes as I said just
chokes his ass out
it's night night she had you know took
three things if I was a woman that I
would work on was a charm bar like a
[ __ ] triangle to the [ __ ] claw the
[ __ ] closed guard you know with a
jacket just reach and put you know cuz
that's the composure of this guy's
taking his belt off he's about to take
his dick off well second drafts at hand
take that blue jacket
pull it around and now he ain't getting
up he might have his dick out but you
got his [ __ ] cuz a jacket is a geek
that's why I don't like when people say
well I don't try I'm like no geet listen
I love noogie because it's a shirt I
could do the same function damage I love
rice when I welcome to a place and I see
somebody with a sweatshirt I know if I
have a problem I got half my game I got
half my game down I pull on the sleeves
lay on my back and I can wrap them up
that's all I want I want to break
nobody's bone
I just want to control a situation
trouble to control the situation you
know right now I'm really considering
competing in the next year
now because it's gonna be like comedy
even though you get beat up you still
rise to the next level when comedy the
more you get beat up the winter when
somebody calls you and you're at the
wrong venue and you go out then you die
a slow death and you go back to you so
much better yeah and that thought of
suicide comes over you for two seconds
and then you're like I'm fine I'm just
Lee the cheeseburger and I'll be on
stage tomorrow that's nice man you've
grown you've grown it doesn't matter
whether you want to lose it's how you
play the game so the next day you show
up tip top with you and even in losing
you've grown you've eliminated that fear
and now you know how to tackle it
because it was fear who beat you yes it
was fear who beat you fear always beat
you in there in there and I was watching
the Creed on the plane on the way back
and he puts it in front of the mirror
and he knows in life I want you to
always remember that that guy is your
biggest out of me and that is so true so
many levels you stop yourself from
either growing you stop you that guy in
the mirror likes to do coke I wouldn't
look at myself in the mirror hmm well I
did coke and I only looked at myself in
the mirror when I called my hair if I
was high I would not look at myself in
the mirror I know it's kind of weird it
makes sense it's it's shame it's like
it's shame I really really really
appreciate you what you do I hate to say
that I appreciate you as a woman I do
you've given a whole new minister balls
in women I like what you're doing with
those young girls I like what you doing
what my daughter won't you know and I
love what you're doing with yourself man
thanks you never [ __ ] know complain
it's me now I have no complaints I'm
good and it just goes to prove to you
that when you wake up in the morning you
put a smile and tell people like when
you attack something like this the other
day I posted something the morning at
7:00 in the morning and somebody
attacked me and for two minutes I had to
think about that's how his day started
hey what's he gonna be like at 3 o'clock
horrible that's why I will night [ __ ] it
is I'm pissing neither will my fat feet
hit the thing and I'm looking my wife's
already in the living room a.m. mercy on
the [ __ ] speaker moving toys and as
I'm pissing I'm looking out the window
and you see that first part of sunshine
I have my how [ __ ] lucky am I and then
you go on the computer you don't care
how many times I put a lot of it it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be like because
I come hoping that somebody is looking
for a shoe it's Monday at 7:45 yeah and
they can't find that [ __ ] shoe and
they think their world is over and I
want them to stop no no wait a second
it's a beautiful day to be alive I'm
working who gives a [ __ ] is my shoes
boss you know what I'm working like a
Hitler till I haven't put the slippers
on I'm going in there fact I'm not
putting socks on put no cream on my feet
Jamaican Jamaica's whatever to make in
whatever I think that when you start the
morning and for years man when I was on
drugs because when you live from day to
day you wake up going today is that day
I'm gonna bug somebody for a kilo of
coke like even if you gonna do something
bad you're like we saw at the laser
today we're gonna hit a pony at the race
we're gonna sell out to come for this
jerk-off and hopefully we get to rob
this other [ __ ] [ __ ] he's gonna show
to how I'm down here with three thousand
in cash so you're always thinking
positively even when you're doing bad
I wish I had that oh it's a man when
you're out there this is this is who
controls your mood you know what I love
people who loved hey listen I believe in
Anthony Robbins but you go one time and
then you learn and you have to motivate
yourself yeah you have to motivate is
that that's it man and I tell it to my
kids all the time you see when they're
like I can't and I'm like that's you
saying that I didn't tell you you can't
do it right so do it right make the
decision right now
like you're in charge of your life and
when I finally went conceptualize that
in my brain I just said [ __ ] it and
created my own lane like I was telling
you like there's not another gym that's
just for women and children to learn
martial arts where is that I created it
because I just said [ __ ] it there isn't
that so I'm gonna make it you you you
are you make your way you make your way
and if you're in your own way you're
gonna be in your own way [ __ ] out of
your own way I was in front of my own
way for [ __ ] years bed and once I got
out of the way I was like wow how easy
is life right it really it really is
easy like I wake up and I'm like I love
everything I'm so grateful
how many people would [ __ ] about
driving to Long Beach five nights a week
I would I would and then I attended
myself how [ __ ] lucky am i right I'm
getting paid to wrestle have a great
time yeah it's how you know when I go to
the gym in the morning huh today as I
was pulling out I was gonna call E and
go how lucky am i that I get to go here
I roll three or four times yeah I get
beat up by two wipeouts my D is drenched
I can feel my [ __ ] under pants okay
soaking on the top of the thing yeah and
I enjoyed it I enjoyed getting choked
out today I enjoy 55 I'm in there just
to be able to go into there 55 year old
people sick right man yeah so I look at
this is such a [ __ ] how lucky we are
yeah that's it it's just great I've
never really offended by anything anyone
says but I remember
about a year ago getting offended by
someone that I thought was a friend
saying not to me to someone else that my
happiness was fake like he'd says
happiness is fake [ __ ] what do you know
how [ __ ] grateful I am to be as happy
as I am I had a really hard life like
[ __ ] you I'm really happy like my life
is fabulous God is [ __ ] good I have
no complaints my happiness is beyond
real this [ __ ] ain't fake you know why
can these people find you this I try to
apply in the [ __ ] website for you I
can't find the websites getting done
right now Louie Buster and I can't find
keto wagon yeah Megha know where the
pretty flower on Instagram keep that
means pretty flower in Swahili so uh my
Instagram is the pretty flower and team
bully buster is the other Instagram for
the company and then you can look us up
on Yelp or Facebook we got great reviews
no you're doing great reviews kids and I
couldn't find your schedule that was the
one thing that's on Yelp and that's also
on Instagram too and on Facebook I think
you do a great job
damn there god I hope people watch you
on when does the season arrest me I
don't know but 21st or 22nd / 10th and
11th we shoot here at the Belasco so if
you guys are interested in seeing some
women's superheroes kick ass come
through and hopefully Helen oh yeah yeah
and she's amazing
if I make girls a part of your wild
production there's a good weave 31
matches we're doing in those two days so
I don't know I think there's 27 of us
and then some of us are wrestling a
couple of times and do any of your girls
graduate to WWE light no some girls
actually were in the WWE so it's kind of
like Bellator in the UFC it's not that
like UFC is bigger but ballot our pay is
better you know what I mean so it's kind
of like that whereas wow superheroes in
WWE it's just it's the one that's fight
I don't know yet
I'll announce that soon you are truly
amazing I love you dearly
I'm happy you took the time talked about
getting bullied and you're very honest
and
like I said my daughters with you so I'm
happy the schedule worked out I mean she
misses master Vinnie yeah but she is
just you know between the gloves and the
head wraps
oh she's beside herself pink so I just
thank you for everything that you do and
continued success and well there's a
season one is room 104 start we're about
to start soon so I think in the next
couple months they've already started
previewing like episodes so and then how
many episodes did you shoot the first
season one it's an anthology show so
each episode will have new actors in the
same place so in room 104 so the concept
of that whole show is the people that
stay in this hotel and the people who
come back to this hotel and stay there
so think about its endless how many
different people stay in a hotel room
[ __ ] tremendous thank you very much
for your time thank you for being thank
you for being positive and follow our on
Facebook Twitter Instagram and if you're
a woman and you listen to this if you
live in the San Fernando Valley honey by
rail I'm telling you go through that her
and coach will blow your [ __ ] mind
thank you very much for your time okay I
want to thank either Megan for coming on
the show there she's a tough girl man
guys she really impresses the [ __ ] out
of me her Facebook page is [ __ ]
amazing she's built and she's created
something on her own that's just special
that's why I take my daughter over and
I'm confident you have the kid go visit
her over there on Whitsett and Riverside
you don't have a great time don't forget
Boston is sold out and Fox was it sold
out but I'm at The Improv in West Palm
Beach
October 11th to October 13th in
Cleveland stay open Miocic
I'm coming to visit you [ __ ] I'm
in Cleveland on the 25th to the 27th at
hilarities so get your tickets you know
what they sell out fast I don't want to
hear stories later that you didn't know
what was going on again I like to
introduce Robin Hood to the
Church family I think this is great when
my wife downloaded the app we went
through it and you know me I don't know
much about this stuff but it's
interesting I'm gonna start investing
and messing around a little bit and see
what's uh out there at the start market
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos commission-free all
commission-free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone
just not the wealthy okay so it's not
intimidating for you to see stop stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence and that's
what it did for me it's simple it's
intuitive and they clear this is our end
with the data presented and it easy to
digest way like I told you me and my
wife downloaded it and I think it's
tremendous the value of Robin Hood is
this alright there's no Commission fees
other brokers charge you up to $10 for
every tenth trade but Robin Hood doesn't
charge a commission fees and all you
trade stocks and you keep all your
profits that's important it's easy to
understand charge and market data place
a trade and just for taps on your smart
phone Robin up web platform also lets
you view stock collections the hundreds
most popular sectors that Kantor
tainment in social media and curated
categories like female CEOs analyst
ratings of buy hold and sell to every
stripe stock now you learn how to invest
as you build your portfolio that's the
most important thing you discover new
stocks and track favorite companies with
personalized newsfeed custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right movement to invest
that's important right there now what
I'm going to do is this Robin Hood is
gonna give the church family a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
you build your portfolio who does this
this is to show you this is to show you
so sign up at Robin Hood calm that's
church dot Robin Hood dot-com again
that's church dot Robin Hood dot-com
this is the way to go it's the investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
and there's no Commission free
again I want you to go to church doc
Robbins odd dot-com now let me tell you
something all right
it's what the second third week of pro
football you got college football and
fall effect you got baseball seat it's
coming to an end the playoffs this is it
this is the time of the year with these
people don't know lines look what
happened on Sunday last week they don't
know their lines this is a time to make
money and I'm showing up to you with a
present my bookie remember who you're
betting on is just as important as who
you bet with that's why I always tell
people to bet with my bookie cuz these
guys don't [ __ ] around trust me guys
they're the best bet this season that
you can make they've been in business
for years and they got great reviews on
lines and their mobile site is nice and
easy to use I would only recommend the
service to the church family that's been
good to me you know why because you win
and they pay that's the point that's why
I'm urging you to make your way to my
bookie
they have in game live betting over and
unders on fantasy point scored and the
most rewarding player perks in the
business my bookie is slam with new
betters all day so what I want to do is
this I want to give everybody the best
possible service so if you're willing to
deposit at 7 p.m. Eastern Time would you
still have time to bet the game whatever
game you want they'll give you an
additional $25 free play on deposits
over on the house so ala that's four
o'clock San Francisco that's four
o'clock Denver that's five o'clock and
whatever Nashville at six o'clock and
then Texas at six o'clock so that's how
we're working this join now and my
bookie will match your deposit dollar
for dollar just enter promo code Church
to activate the offer okay so visit my
bookie online today just do me a favor
you're gonna bet anyway let's do it the
right way when creating your account
press and enter promo code Church and
claim up to $1,000 in free play now if
you're willing to hold out till 7:00
p.m. I'm gonna throw you an extra 25 by
using the promo code enter promo code
Church and add 25 to the end
so that's Church 25 I'm gonna get you 25
beads and it's up to you guys but I'd
wait until after dinner and take the
extra money so do me a favor
check out my book UI you play you win
you get paid who's better than you I
want to thank him I want to thank my
bookie and I want to thank Robin Hood
for supporting the podcast but more
importantly I want to thank you savages
for keeping us in lewd and [ __ ] tuned
and making sure that we're here for you
every [ __ ] day this fly hasn't told
his cousin what fly leaves the other one
comes in you Antley stop with your pet
[ __ ] flies on your neck anyway don't
forget West Palm Beach
October 11th through the 13th and then
I'm in Cleveland October 25th through
the 27th at hilarious get your tickets
now don't come to me later uncle Joey I
slipped I [ __ ] up I didn't know like I
said I don't go out much the Netflix
special will be at the end of October I
don't know when I'll let you know as it
gets closer and that's it and that's
that for my Jewish family happy Yom
Kippur
you know I love you [ __ ] stay
black see you Monday more than one
another [ __ ] tremendous podcast I
love you guys have a great weekend I'll
see you Monday morning bright and early
and for my Jewish family Yom Kippur
[ __ ]
stay black kick that meal leave